[Music]
before we move on to the binomial
theorem we need to learn an important
and interesting concept we need to know
something called the Pascal's triangle
wondering what it is come let's see the
Pascal's triangle is a triangle made up
of numbers is that it
no of course there's more to it let's
see what a Pascal's triangle actually
looks like looks something like this
do you observe any pattern here have a
closed low in the Pascal's triangle each
number is the sum of the two numbers
directly above it yes notice that 2 is
the sum of 1 and 1 this 3 is the sum of
1 and 2 and this 3 is the sum of 2 and
121 is the sum of 6 and 15 and so on
what else to be notice we also see that
the starting and the ending numbers are
always 1 in each row yes all the numbers
on the extreme left and all the numbers
on the extreme right are all one in the
Pascal's triangle the rows are numbered
starting from 0 this is the zeroth row
this is the first one then the second
one and so on the third row is 1 3 3 1
the fifth row is 1 5 10 10 5 1 and so on
and you may be wondering why we need
such a trial what do we even do with it
don't worry you'll get to know that soon
first let me tell you some real
interesting facts about the Pascal's
triangle take a look here at these two
diagonals on either side what are they
oh yes they are the set of natural
numbers awesome isn't it
can you find more patterns here
check out these two diagonals what could
these possibly be the numbers are 1 3 6
10 15 and so on for each number let's
imagine the same number of circles let's
arrange them like this what do you see
we see that for each number we can form
equilateral triangles three can be
arranged like this six can be arranged
like this and so on such a set of
numbers is called as a set of triangular
numbers interesting right now let me ask
you the same question again do you
notice any other pattern it could be
anything give it a shot I want you to
observe each row let's see what happens
when we add up the numbers in each row
of the Pascal's triangle try adding up
the numbers in the second row adding up
these numbers gives us four now can you
try adding the numbers in the third and
the fourth row individually what numbers
do you get
yes we get eight and sixteen do you see
a pattern here
4 8 16 and so on 4 can be written as 2
square 8 is 2q 16 is 2 raise to 4 and so
on how can we generalize this pattern
yes the sum of each row can be
represented as a 2 raised to the number
of the row you can check it out for any
row take the seventh row for instance we
will get the sum as 128 which is nothing
but 2 raise to 7 so many patterns right
but you may be wondering how will we use
this Pascal's triangle in the binomial
theorem let's see how can you tell me
the formula of a plus B the whole square
yes it's a squared plus 2 a B plus B
squared
can you tell me what the power of the
binomial here is you're right it's to
this power is also called the index of
the binomial now before we proceed
further we need to know what binomial
coefficients are binomial coefficients
are the coefficients of each term in the
expansion of the binomial can you tell
me what the binomial coefficients here
are yes they are one two and one
now let's go back and see the Pascal's
triangle can you tell me the numbers in
the second row
the numbers in the second row are the
same as the coefficients in the
expansion but index two now let's try it
out with another expansion let's
consider a plus B the whole cubed and we
know it's formula right yes it's a cubed
plus 3a squared B plus 3a B squared plus
B cubed
what are the coefficients here they are
1 3 3 & 1 are the numbers the same as
that of the third row of the Pascal's
triangle oh yes they are so what can we
conclude from this we can say that each
row in a Pascal's triangle gives us the
binomial coefficients for the expansion
having any index
[Music]
you